welcome back to Las Vegas now Eric
Palacios from Eric Palacios and
Associates the sponsors of this segment
shares three things you should know
about ensuring a classic car
welcome to the legal minute today we're
going to tell you three things you
should know about ensuring a classic or
specialty car number one if you have
regular car insurance for your classic
or exotic car you're making an expensive
mistake regular car insurance will
generally pay the perceived or utility
value of a classic or old car for
example if you have a Classic 60s truck
that might be worth forty thousand
dollars to you but in the eyes of the
insurance company it's only worth a few
thousand dollars number two you should
have classic car insurance for your
Specialty Vehicle or classic car this
insurance costs about one tenth of the
cost of regular Insurance because
there's less risk you don't drive your
classic every day and number three with
classic car insurance you set the value
of the car ahead of time if it's ever
damaged or stolen you will recuperate
your investment and not have to fight
the insurance company on the value of
the car thank you for being here on the
legal minute we'll see you next time
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
at
702-44-777 or visit their website at
Eric palacioslaw.com we will be right
back